you have missing links this drone
follows the power lines they carry 110
volts of electricity traditionally
special teams climb the towers for a
visual inspection or helicopters follow
the lungs but the drone can view them
from every angle and send real-time
images back to the pilot the use of
drones saves the power company time and
money I like that the first advantage is
we can inspect towers and powerline
safely when inspectors have to climb
there's always a certain danger and
second we get high resolution pictures
immediately losing build up drones for
business and industry are built in this
hall Micro drones has 25 employees it's
aight engineers are kept busy designing
drones each with different abilities and
tasks the flying objects take extensive
tests to ensure they can accelerate to
60 kilometers an hour they cost from
10,000 to a hundred thousand euros and
can fly for up to an hour and a half
drones are also used to inspect railway
tracks or to bring medicines to people
who live on North Sea Islands Sven us
took over the company from his father
most of his customers use drones to save
money close to public office in the
catch-all term is industrial inspection
anywhere there is infrastructure or
buildings that have to be maintained
they have to be inspected and drones do
that well our business is doing very
well and will continue to growth by
micro drones has licensed a company in
China to produce quadrocopter drones to
and the Chinese have prospects of
landing a commission to produce 195
drones pretty busy
we launched this partnership in China in
2008 they now have a staff of 80 they've
grown more than we have there I don't
know whether to cheer all weep lock the
whole was ill licensed production in
China and its own manufacture both mean
profits for the company a new customer
wants to buy a drone for a wildlife
preserve in Africa their chief test
pilot demonstrates consult with the
cameras search function the drone
recognizes details on the ground it ties
a warden Eric in the flying camera sees
more than an unaided human eye it only
the drone makes it possible to get
closer to poachers to check whether the
animals in a particular area are where
they belong or whether there are also
people there who don't belong in the
area what isn't that I've mentioned you
to thank you can go hunt this drone will
cost forty thousand euros now it has to
prove itself in practice by catching or
deterring poachers in Africa
you